everyone welcome to LED live here's a
question we get asked a lot what can i
watch find out on this episode of LED
live welcome everyone we want to thank
all the people who support us and make
this show possible LED live would not be
possible without you our supporters and
so we want to thank our patrons and if
you want to learn more about that or
find out what is a patron and what is
patreon what are you guys talking about
all the time you can go to
patreon.com/scishow little light studios
you'll see us there you'll see all the
perks you'll see how to support us there
are many different levels all the way
from $1 to get early access to well
sky's the limit
we won't restrict ya be sure to tune in
for our supporters at $5 we have a
patreon push show discussion where you
get to see a little more of us a little
less formal not that this is entirely
formal but a little less formal you get
these behind-the-scenes discussions you
get to see take 1 2 3 4 takes in the
office sometimes just you know it's it's
it's a mixed bag of extra content just
for you we also have cool t-shirts why
because we get to come to a workplace
where we like teachers now not wearing
one today but I like I wonder will work
in a t-shirt like he's wearing because
it's comfortable I mean who doesn't like
them to work in a t-shirt and jeans
right yeah
so we like t-shirts Mikey's got a
t-shirt check out our t-shirts on
teespring we got a lot of creative
designs there today we're gonna be
talking about how to be media savvy when
it comes to what we watch how we
approach the media in general what is it
that I should take in through my eyes
and a good documentary to help guide you
in that is called sutala to the art of
line it's a documentary that our
organization made and we encourage you
to check it out on our stoop in our
store little light studios TV slash shop
or you can get a DVD but you don't have
to just get a DVD you can get a digital
download
memmio so this is one big one commercial
for us because we're the ones doing the
show right yeah so go to Vimeo check out
how you can get a digital download you
can rent it you can buy it either way
and we appreciate your support in that
you're doing it that way we also like to
hear from you the people who watch our
show put some comments on YouTube we
read them ly respond to them as many as
possible and we enjoy getting the
feedback from you and learning what it
is that you're looking for whatever your
mind is that we enjoy engaging with
people and we want you to post a comment
rather whether you agree with us or not
right so we appreciate hearing other
people's perspectives comments actually
helped us design or later shirt too so
yeah we have goals sometimes there you
go so today today we're gonna talk about
learning to be media wise and in this
presentation we're gonna look at a lot
of Scripture and principles to help
guide and shape our lives when we make
decisions about what to consume in the
media that can be the internet could be
videogames it could be TV it could be
movies you name it social media these
principles can help guide our lives okay
so this is not a list of ten principles
but there's principles okay so I
encourage you before we get too far into
this um if you have a pen and paper take
notes or go back through this thing and
watch it again because there's a lot in
here that I'm not gonna spell out every
verse for you we're gonna list them and
we're gonna have a free download that
you can get so look in the description
below to get a deeper study if you will
on this topic where you can explore this
with your Bible and decide how God is
leading you so what you're not gonna get
today and I hate to say that what you're
not gonna get what you're not gonna get
is two lists the good list and the bad
list yeah we don't do that sorry if it
disappointing you because that's
probably what you are 1tb and you barely
were wanting that and so if that's a
huge disappointment you're gonna cut out
right here sorry we get that a lot like
people are like well can you make a move
can you make a show about all the good
movies
yeah why do we not do that well go ahead
because generally if if we put something
down on the list we say this one's good
this one because this one's good and
this one's bad this one's bad then all
of a sudden people if it's not on the
list then it's just fair game so we
would rather try to teach the principles
of of what makes that you know decision
possible between a good and bad movie
rather than just like oh well let me
just check the list let me see what
these guys said and if they if they
agree with it being a good movie then I
guess it's good for all of us you know
yeah that's a big responsibility that I
don't personally want to be held
accountable for especially you know if
you say well I really recommend this
movie it had a lot of good things in and
somebody's like did you hear the music
did you see the way that person was
dress you're never gonna please
everybody so it's best just to give
principles and let the person pray for
the guidance the Holy Spirit and use
these principles
yeah there's no network or studio that
you could rubber stamp right I mean we
had a question come in and people were
like well what about hard mark you know
they make these clean you know this
lovey-dovey
you know nice little stories and and
yeah I would say for the most part they
probably do but then shortly after that
you know what you know what happened you
remember yeah I think it was a gay
marriage leasing and some commercials on
their network because of the content
which was same-sex relationship
promotion and then they caved to that
pressure and then it was even stated
that you know well you know we're even
entertaining doing these kind of
programs in the future so it's kind of
like if we would have sit there and be
like yeah everything hallmark makes is
good that woulda went right out there
and real quick yeah Sesame Street that's
been on for 50 years and all the sudden
the dudes on there and address yeah yeah
so no rubber stamp it's the teach demand
of fish concept exactly teach the man to
fish there you go so here's where I'd
like to start the question is media
powerful I think this is some common
ground that we can all approach this
topic from media is very powerful in
fact the average
industry is probably one of the
strongest examples that media is really
powerful
why else would intelligent people spend
well these intelligent people they run
big corporations - right
they plunked down 5.6 million dollars
for 30 seconds Wow
for commercial okay that was the latest
Super Bowl cost 5.6 million dollars for
30 seconds so no discount for a minute
11 points you million dollars that is a
hundred and eighty six thousand six
hundred and sixty six dollars and change
per second it's not like a lot of sixes
in there and and you know what's crazy
is like I saw Walmart had I think four
or five or six different commercials
during the Superbowl I mean just think
about that they threw down like 30
million mm-hmm they wouldn't do that if
they didn't think that it would have
some sort of effect right so they Bank
their business on your likeliness to
remember their message and respond to it
in a way that benefits them so a great
example people that are really smart
running large corporations they're
giving money into networks I mean just
burning through it because they know it
works I know they're gonna get the
return on that you know they're gonna
get the return and all this really
happens in one place right happens where
happens in your mind yeah right that's
what they're really going after going
after the mind there's a neurologist dr.
G Richard G Pellegrino and he said this
when he was talking about music he's
been working on the brain and looking at
the effects of music for like 25 years
he says there's nothing that he does can
affect a person's state of mind the way
one simple song
and those little jingles that they write
in those commercials I mean those are
it's specifically designed like like to
be these catchy little tune I mean can
you guys sing some commercials got up
there's not a single there's not one
commercial that doesn't have a jingle
that's a music okay
that's right for this reason those
jingles stick inside of your brain and
then they associate their product with
that jingle I was just talking about
Mikey the other day that's like do you
remember the McDonald's commercial where
the Ronald McDonald it's like do you
believe in magic you know that was like
it in the 80s still remember it's crazy
I'm always a I think back to this quote
by Oscar Wilde often it says life
imitates art far more than art imitates
life I think that's so true yeah in fact
87% of entertainment industry leaders
feel that violence and mass media
contributes to violence in society you
want to see that number again yeah
87 percent Wow these are entertainment
leaders you know they they realize and
recognize the power that they their
industry has and the power of creative
content so let's start with some
questions is it I'm gonna have several
key questions through all this and we're
gonna go through some information our
first key question will be what does it
cause me to think about hmm what does
the movie cause you to think about
whatever it is I think you need the game
that you're playing it could be the site
that you're surfing it could be the
social media you know that you're going
through night after night what does it
cause me to think about I'll just pick
on fortnight there's like if you're
playing for tonight I gotta die yeah
shooting everybody and then dancing over
their dead body what does that making
you think about you know I think that
there's a difference between that game
and let's say you're playing tennis with
Wii or something that someone do so keep
that in mind as we go through some of
this
so this related question although it's
not one of our key questions is what
does that mean for me right why is it so
hard to keep God in first place
well their flesh is at enmity with God
right yeah if you think about this
before we accept Christ as our Savior we
are controlled by the flesh it's what
the Bible tells us right it's our sinful
nature and our selfish desires you know
if I do a reality check on
against the Bible you know I'd like to
think I'm a certain kind of person but
in the end of you know I am a prideful
selfish control freak that's what I am
you know that's that's the reality of
the Bible and so what I need to do is
over come that through Christ power and
to do that we need to become a new
creation right when we make Jesus our
Lord the Bible tells us we become new
creations what what does that mean if
you're a new creation what does that
mean for your life moving forward I
think yeah you know if your tastes for a
certain particular type of thing is an
old way of your life it's like you have
new tastes now new things that excite
you new things that you want to talk
about you know for me you know I used to
love to like uber violent movies like
more guns the better just just come out
like body counting blazing and when I
kind of really got converted back it's
like I don't want to see that and so to
me I can experience that that new
creation is just like my my my desires
changed isn't it weird thinking back on
those times because I was the same way
metal music horror movies and and drugs
and all that and I look back and like
who was that different life different
world yeah for people who are struggling
this is such good news
yeah think about if you have some kind
of addiction you don't want to be that
old person anymore
you want to be made new right because
you are bound by a chain a chain of
addiction that's not gonna let you go
alright something has to break of that
chain so this is good news so often
times we can struggle struggle with this
topic and but I like this thing over
here you know I like playing this or
watching this or participating in this
and if it doesn't line up with the Bible
you can see how you're chained to that
you know and and how you need to become
that new creation like what you said on
I think it was on the out house but
you're saying we often say well I was
born this way it's in my DNA or whatever
and then God says but I can change you
then all of a sudden it's like but I
don't want to change you know
right that's really the heart of the
issue yeah when when when somebody's
like you know I was born with these
sinful propensities you know God is
promising he can take those and reshape
them the Bible tells us when we've been
made this new creation it says in
galatians chapter 5 and they that are
Christ's have been crucified with the
flesh with the affections and lusts if
we live in the spirit let us also walk
in the spirit right so when we when
we've been made this new creation we are
under now the control of the Holy Spirit
and that's a good thing right because
we're not being left to our own desires
anymore
Bible tells us in Romans chapter 6 that
we we should not serve sin any longer
so we have to we have to check our our
choices and this is good news again
nobody wants to be a slave right which
is what when we are bound by sin that's
what we are we are a slave to sin and
it's good news that we do not have to be
a slave anymore we do not have to serve
sin we should not serve sin and by the
power of Christ that is possible people
ask us well why do we do this what why
do we have this ministry and speaking of
thinking what you just said I'm reminded
of Harriet Tubman who's like you know
has saved so many people and I would
have been able to save so many more if
they only knew they were enslaved we're
here really seeking to show people that
yes unknowingly some people are enslaved
and if they can just understand that
then they can take these steps to to
become free no more good news
sin shall not have dominion over you
this is fantastic news for anybody who
is struggling with anything right we
don't have to be slaves to sin you can
plot along in life doing your own thing
right and you can be confidently
believing that everything that you are
doing is right but if you have not
consulted the Word of God how are you
going to know right so all of our
choices in life whether it's media
choices or other choices they have to be
put up against something right and the
only way that you're gonna know what
that is is by reading and studying along
so
we're gonna admonish you're gonna
encourage you study the Bible right this
is how you're gonna find out if
something is in your life is something
that Christ wants you to have or he
doesn't want you to have and if he says
no I want you to give that up
it's only for your good no he's not
gonna do or take away for you anything
that is for your good and he's so
willing to give good gifts right more
than a parent is willing to give a child
their gift God is willing to give us
good gifts so we should be studying the
Bible tells us in Colossians 2:8 beware
lest any man spoil you through
philosophy and vain deceit after the
tradition of men after the rudiments of
the world and not after Christ so
there's a contrast here right there is
men and the world and there is Christ
and those things are not on the same
path right the Bible says there is a way
that seems right to a man good verse
right but what happens with that way it
means it leads to death right and so we
we have to again go back to the Bible
and say what is it at Christ ones
because what I want is probably gonna
lead to death and I don't want that all
right none of us want that the reality
of life is that there is a war going
inside each one of us right and so we
have to face that war we have to decide
what side we're gonna be on in that war
and we have to go to we have to go to
battle Ephesians 2 1 through 5 tells us
that the sinful nature brings death all
right
fe Jones for 17 through 24 tells us
basically if I'm or gonna get to the
heart of that passage you know it's out
with the old in with the new right
talking about that old man again here's
a couple of verses from there it says
that you put off concerning the former
conversation the old man which is
corrupt according to deceitful lusts and
be renewed in the spirit of your mind
notice again the mind and that you put
on the new man which after God is
created in righteousness and true
holiness
what does it mean to be righteous right
doing right doing okay what does it mean
to be holy yeah yeah pure or set apart
is another way I've heard of it right I
want to touch on death there was a verse
you were talking about it says lead to
death and there's seems to be different
forms of death you have eternal death
that's based off of your choice of which
side you choose and how you live your
life but then I feel like there's like
like a mental death which can be equated
to sadness you guys ever heard the
question people ask why Christians so
happy like what is there to be happy
about it's like this this mental peace
that you get based off of what you
believe in and the way you live your
life and so when applying to what we
take in saying that our choices lead to
death it's like it can lead to
unhappiness which do you choose
happiness or unhappiness life or death
I'm not sure if you're gonna bring up
these verses Ecclesiastes 11:10 I don't
know but I have that one what in 1st
Corinthians 13:11 but I was just
remembering this one verse and
Ecclesiastes 11:10 says therefore remove
sorrow from thy heart and put away evil
from thy flesh for childhood and youth
are vanity which is a good parallel to
1st Corinthians 13:11 where he says when
I was a child I spake as a child I
understood as a child I thought as a
child but when I became a man I put away
childish things like for tonight yeah
you know you're sparking my memory like
Matthew 5:8 says blessed are the pure in
heart for they shall see God no you
don't I mean it's like you need this
kind of childlike purity right that that
basically is is promised I mean that's
that's Jesus speaking Sermon on the
Mount you know it's like these people
that have that purity are gonna see
going so it's a shift in the mindset
it's not what can I get away with it's
how hi can I gain there you go and it's
not easy it's a struggle Paul struggled
with this we know this from Romans
chapter 7 it was it's it's not an easy
thing to do there are things in this
life that we struggle and battle against
again it's a war
but in that war we know what the cure is
and the core that cure is Jesus right we
know that from Romans and so I'm just
gonna distill one of the texts out of
that passage it says and if Christ being
you the body is dead because of sin but
the Spirit is life because of
righteousness now if you're dead you
can't sin right person doesn't say
that's that's a beautiful thought right
and if you are created new and that new
creator is that new creatures powered
and fuelled by the Holy Spirit and it's
a creature that relies on the power of
God then as you choose to abide there
guess what then you won't say Yeah right
because it's Christ living in you and
our Christ does not sin that's right
right but you have to choose for Christ
to do that you can't do it by yourself
there's no way we can't do it with our
own selves if we could we wouldn't need
God right
thank God won't just forcefully now
you're a Christian you're gonna obey
like he's knocking you know you got an
answer that's right all right here's
another key question where does it turn
my affections - mm-hmm
I mean you mean that piece of media that
media where does it turn my affections -
and so when we're talking about that
what we're really talking about is
exposure right we have to be careful
what we expose ourselves to right I was
just reading this morning in a book I'm
finishing up this book called the
tech-wise family and the author was just
going over pornography right people get
exposed to pornography and it's so hard
for them to break away from that right
we have to be careful about what we take
in because it can change our affections
or we can put our affections on
something just like with pornography
especially you know it's like you see
something and then it's like you get
hooked and that's what your affections
are on because you've been exposed to it
Psalm says and 101:3 I will set no
wicked thing before my eyes I hate the
work of them to turn aside it shall not
claim to me here we have David's pledge
of purity David knew that by putting
these things before his eyes it would
have a corrupting influence and that's
why he was pledging that I'm not gonna
do that I'm not gonna put these things
before my eyes because I know how it's
going to affect me
fusions chapter 5 encouraged us to live
live in the light rather than darkness
right and so even even a verse that we
use we even have we have t-shirts about
it we have a sticker we're developing
about it's Ephesians 5:11 which says and
have no fellowship with the works of
Darkness right but rather expose them
and darkness can only be exposed by
light right so we have to or we should
seek to live in the light and who is the
true light it's Jesus Christ right we
want to live our lives in the light of
Christ if we're not living in the light
of Christ where are we we're in the
darkness and you know in the dark is
where we try to hide things we try to
hide the things of our lives we try to
you know put things there that we don't
other people to see it's you know for
the most part none of us probably
generally want to go down a dark alley
why it doesn't seem safe right there's
all these metaphors throughout life that
we can draw on when it comes to light
and darkness but we want to live in the
life of Christ the Bible admonished us
this that we should test everything
right first Thessalonians 5:21 prove all
things hold fast that which is good so
test everything just because a preacher
said it doesn't make it true just
because we say it yeah that's right
instant just because it's on the
Internet sorry hope you knew this but if
you didn't it's not true just because
it's on the Internet there's no
regulation there and like Mikey said
whatever you tell whatever you we tell
you double-check us we're not another
thing I want to encourage people do is
don't waver on the truth just because it
sounds look good and you like hearing it
doesn't mean it will turn you to the
truth the Bible tells us is in the last
days that people will turn to the type
of content that will steer them away
from the truth mmm all right they'll
turn to fables yes
means that are good too they're itching
ears and all this sounds good makes you
feel good but it's not the truth yeah
right so we don't want to waver on truth
when we confront truth in the Bible I'm
gonna say okay that's the way walk in it
you know and Christ will give me the
strength and power to walk in that way
there's another key question will it
dull my awareness to God's presence in
the midst of a cloud spells good
question
so not just a midst of it after as well
oh yeah after it as well I mean you know
he's used to think when I was entrenched
in the things that I was watching like
what if Jesus came back and I was
watching whatever or I was in a theater
or you know something like that
but it makes you uncomfortable at least
it at least it did me yeah and I was
like man you know like oh that would be
an awkward situation for sure Jesus
comes back and I'm sitting there kickin
back watching something it's like yeah
what do you say to that
you know it's like it's like being
caught red-handed right I mean you don't
have any excuse especially if it's
ungodly and often we think about like
what if Jesus would come back but the
reality is as he's there right there all
the time I'm sorry we use there we
should just think about it like that so
we need a good defense right we need to
prepare a good defense for our our minds
and our hearts when it comes to media
psalm 119:11 says thy word have I hid in
my heart that I might not sin against
thee so one of the ways that we can
defend our heart defend our minds
against the world is by putting the word
of God in our mind and then it will be
there when these critical moments come
and you have to make these decisions uh
should I should I do this should I watch
this should I listen to this that word
of god will come back to you because
this appear the Spirit will supply it
and say you know yeah I mean that's God
you should listen to it or no you don't
want anything to do with that right but
you're not gonna know the difference one
way or the other if you don't read the
truth and put the truth
we need me to be transformed right and
we talked about this earlier putting off
the old man dying to sand all of that
but Romans 12:2 encourages us not to be
conformed to this world but to be
transformed by the renewing of our minds
and this is a great defense because it
goes back to that that earlier idea
right that that new mind has a defense
because it's it's dead to the old ways
it's dead to sin right and so it's like
sin has no power to do anything it's a
great defense right and I want to
mention something that when when we've
kind of analyzed the transgender
movement and specifically in conjunction
with entertainment and they have placed
upon the entertainment industry to put X
amount percent of transgender people in
there right why why do they care if it's
20% or 30% or 50% or why are they
pushing why are they pushing for that
because it's it's just a piece of media
yeah if I can affect anybody right so
when you think about that being totally
transformed I mean you can see how the
media will transform you and make you
Pro sensitive towards those subjects or
whatever and just by seeing it that's
simply what they're hoping for if enough
people see enough transgender people
then they'll be accepting of it all
around well look it works on the other
side of the fence as well you are
transformed so then therefore if you're
watching things that are pure or things
that are good you're most likely gonna
be transformed into that if you're
watching things that are evil or
whatever you're gonna be transformed
into that yeah another principle that we
we need to learn is we have to take our
thoughts prisoner just because you have
a transformed mind doesn't mean you are
not immune to the little whisperings of
Satan here and there he's gonna try to
work his way in any way that he can you
know even Jesus was tempted yeah so we
have to learn to take those thoughts
into captive and into captivity and put
them you know in a prison put them
behind us you know ask Christ to take it
away so I encourage you to look at
second Corinthians chapter 10 verses
three through five on that and
learning how to take those thoughts
prisoner so that they're not just freely
out there in your mind you know you
don't want to be dwelling on things that
are unclean or defiling or going to be a
trap to you right
that's just like if you're a guy you see
an attractive woman in a store you don't
sit there and be like oh you know just
really turned him just keep thinking
about it and thinking about anything
about it's not good for your
relationship with God or your wife to do
that you know if you notice somebody's
attractive she's attractive that's nice
okay yeah you go on the other way you
notice people all the time there's
nothing wrong with noticing something
but you don't want to dwell on things
that are evil because they will just rot
your brain the best way to overcome is
to in that moment physically say a
prayer you know when I was God
supernaturally freed me from addiction
overnight but the temptation was still
there like when I say supernaturally I
mean like there was no withdrawals but
then I every day after that there's
still the temptation and and I would
physically lord give me the strength not
to go in and buy that or whatever you
know we need to do the same thing with
everything Lord I'm tempted to watch
this that I shouldn't watch you know
give me this strength and and claim a
promise from the Bible you know another
way that we can have a defense is by
putting on the armor of God right and
we've talked about this in other
programs all these pieces of the armor
are attributable to crust and so when
we're putting this armor on we're
putting on Jesus right that's what the
full armor of God is all about it's
putting on Jesus and when we have Jesus
on that's a great defense right because
Jesus is not he's not gonna be held by
sin Sinton doesn't have an effect on him
he's overcome sin he's overcome the
grave he's overcome all these things he
has all the power and so he can supply
you with the victory if you just secure
yourself in him so put on the armor of
God Bible admonishes us also to be holy
follow the commander right God is
calling us to live a holy life and that
is empowering it's it means that we are
to be set apart and that becomes part of
our life
it means your activities your dress
the things you eat or drink it means all
of your life Christ has a say in all of
our life amen
right if there's a part of your life
that you think Christ does not have a
say in then I would you know I would
seriously think about that because he's
supposed to be the Lord and Master yeah
so we don't want to withhold anything
from him because he he has all these
blessings that he wants to bestow upon
us and we need to follow him and be holy
as he is holy and he's the one that's
called us to be holy another defense
would be learning to be wise right
proverbs chapter 3 verses 21 through 26
talks about the benefits of discernment
and then Ecclesiastes 9 I'll just pull
out a little bit from here it says
wisdom is better in weapons of war but
one sinner destroys much good you think
about that we're talking about this as a
war as a battle you know you need wisdom
is what the Bible says you need that for
discernment so that you can have the
best defense possible against the
attacks of the enemy and guard your life
my people are destroyed for lack of
knowledge that's right you guys and
proverbs say the beginning of wisdom is
the fear of the Lord
yeah that's right that's right the Bible
has a lot to say about with them so you
want to look at the handout we can
include more verses about wisdom in that
prayer right prayer is a huge part of
the Christians experience and we need to
be praying as part of our defense to
keep these things at bay right the Bible
you know we were admonished and the
Lord's Prayer lead us not into
temptation why why would we pray that
because we're so prone with our selfish
nature to just walk right into it yeah
right I mean if there's evil and sinful
humanity will find it or created all
right so we need to be praying that God
will lead us in the right way and that's
a great defense pray for wisdom and that
will help you with your media standards
pray for strength and I'll supply verses
for this and
and oh and we should pray pray for the
Holy Spirit to help you understand what
the Bible has to say about entertainment
principles and they are principles
because it's not like the Bible says
thou shalt not go to a movie yeah
doesn't say that right just like it
doesn't it doesn't say you shall not
smoke cigarettes but there are
principles in there about our health and
there's principles in there about our
mental health and so we can use these
but we need to pray about them because
we don't want to distort or mishandle
the Word of God to our own desires all
right that's what we want to be guarded
against another important thing is walk
with wise people right your friends can
be very important and you want to choose
wise friends wise peers you oftentimes
become like the people you surround
yourself with right you wind up talking
like them you wind up you know having
the same little habits that they do I'll
just I'm totally guilty right now my
wife notices that all the time from
being around Scotty
[Laughter]
and you know I picked that up in
California and so I don't even notice
picked it up from him some time together
over the past however many years it's
been so you pick up on little things
like that and I remember in high school
then I picked up some bad habits being
in the wrong crowd you know the I was I
was like the little nerd kid right and
so what happened was is the the guys
they didn't want to spend too much time
on their homework who were probably up
to no good they wanted to hang out with
me and so I had you know my a lot of
friends and probably not so good crowd
because they wanted to take my homework
out of my locker or you know and copy it
or stuff like this and it's like you
pick up those habits of those people
their language the things they do
sometimes the way they walk I mean all
kinds of stuff so you want to surround
yourself with really good friends and
people that are gonna keep you in check
Christian people right people that are
following the Word of God that are
upholding the Bible and Christian media
standards
and you said something interesting you
didn't even notice it so you're like
write it out keep thinking that you're
Keith you know you haven't picked up and
you totally did yeah I mean those those
friends that are you know constantly
trying to entice you to go see certain
movies and stuff that can be a powerful
force as well is I know you know
especially young kids my kids are at the
age now where it's like they're just
starting to hang out with other kids and
some of the kids would be like you know
talking about have you seen this movie
or that movie and if they haven't seen
it then those kids are what why haven't
you seen this you know and they like
make them feel bad that they haven't
actually seen these things so you know
it's it's interesting but that just
progressively can get worse down the
road I mean I I know
I was always getting asked to go see
movies and stuff with my friends in
college and you know they were terrible
terrible movies looking back on it so
those influences can definitely be a
powerful force in your life as well so
if you find yourself kind of like keep
having these friends that are drawing
you into worldliness or or you know
going and doing those things you might
want to re-evaluate that or set some
boundaries with your friends
it's tough we get the challenge but it
makes it easier if you can surround
yourself with people who can give you
good counsel and we'll make a stand
there's a difference between truth and
reality
right what does portrayed as good or
evil can change based on the whims and
desires of men we see that in our own
modern society and that's that's one of
the probably the most alarming things is
what is right and wrong seems to be
changing with generations right and so
we have to be careful with that truth on
the other hand is it subjective it's a
turtle and it's absolutely right truth
does not change and for the Christian
the truth is grounded in the Word of God
right and Jesus himself said I am the
way the truth and the life right you
want to know truth you want to be in
truth follow Jesus you can never go
wrong following Jesus what does the
Bible say about truth it says that it
sets us free it says that it sanctifies
us and at pura
and if you don't see those principles
working out into your life go back to
the Word of God see how it can set you
free see how I can sanctify you see well
what needs to be purified in your life
right mm-hmm
another key question is it excellent
according to God's standards yeah I just
keep going back to if if you can
honestly imagine sitting down in
whatever X movie in heaven and I mean
like like you got all the angels with
you and stuff if you can imagine
yourself doing that and imagine Jesus or
anyone from heaven for that matter
sitting there with you that might be a
good barometer for like is this is this
okay for me to digest I mean I could
totally see them you know sitting down
and watching like you know some sort of
planet Earth thing you know not the
billions of years but you know what I
mean like something that like like
highlights God's creation or something
that's that's a very positive thing or a
story that really has a real positive
outcome I could maybe see that but not
something where they're like you know
Heat they're robbing a bank or something
yeah I mean like I used to I used to
park cars and I would get it and we live
in the south so I always hear these
country stations all the time and there
is a song it was like I'm gonna have a
beer with Jesus and I'm like country
music they have a way of combined
everything's like I'm gonna have a beer
and say a prayer and it's all American
and God but I still drink beer and cheat
on her wife sand and blend a lot of that
we have to be careful not to bring down
God to our level mm-hmm and and what I
mean by that is our standards what we
think is right and wrong Christ comes
down to our level but he does it to lift
us up live just higher you know to pull
us out of the pit that we're in God has
a standard he actually wrote it down
right and when it comes to our media
standards we should base them on the
Word of God right there's no other
standard and I would encourage you when
it comes to developing media standards
in your life write them down write
solidify that commitment
buy-rite it taking the time to write
them out and say this is what I am going
to commit to this is what I'm gonna hold
to and it's based on these verses here
so that you know when somebody asks you
why why do you do the things you do or
why do you watch that or not watch that
or listen to this or not listen to that
you can say well I do it for these
reasons here let me show you and you can
refer back to that you know memorize
them I see a picture of the 10
commandments there if you looked at -
I'll not take the Lord's name in vain
there'd be a lot of programs you
wouldn't be able to watch I've noticed
that that even if a show or movie
doesn't have you know a lot of sexual
themes or violence they seem to always
take his name in vain
and it's amazing in Jewish culture they
wouldn't even say God's name because it
was that they were that respectful of it
you know it was like you know we're just
not worried did it come off my tongue
yeah they just had a reverence for it
and in our world today it's like just
people use it as a curse word you know
it's terrible people are so funny I
don't understand why it's so hard to
understand the concept take God's name
out and put your name right do you
realize how many people how many times a
day people say oh my god it was like oh
my Scotty oh my oh my Scotty you didn't
even you know any like what what do you
want picture God like you know yeah
that's that's how I like to think about
things so to help me really understand
it and get closer to God and also apply
it to my life okay that makes perfect
sense maybe I should stop doing that no
it's not gonna be easy right none of
this is necessarily what I would call
easy it will take sacrifice but God does
not call you to sacrifice anything that
is not good for your own good nor does
God ask you to come to him and do as you
please right you know whatever whatever
you want to do that's fine it's gonna
take work it's gonna be hard work you're
gonna have to make choices and those
choices you know they're just they're
not easy easy it's like you know when it
comes to your friends there gonna be
times where you're gonna have to
seriously say you know what this is not
something that I should put before my
eyes or put in my ears and
sorry but I'm not gonna do that and
you're gonna have to take a stand and
it's not easy
but Christ can give you strength to do
that you know and when you start to make
those steps towards making those
decisions you'll become stronger and
stronger and stronger each time yeah and
when it comes to taking a stand of the
things of this world you may be faced
with much more challenging decisions
later on and if you can you know learn
to solidify your decisions on the little
things
then when bigger things come along it's
not gonna be as hard right and you may
get made fun of or something at the
beginning but guess what you're making a
better impact in the long run because
when that person reaches a point where
they maybe are considering Christianity
you're gonna be the one that didn't look
like a hypocrite that stood on solid
ground that really looked like a true
Christian and you're gonna be the one
that people start to recognize as a
pseudo Authority right because they're
like oh that person's in a Christian and
what they're talking about actually who
asked then it's just like my wife is
really into cooking and and you know
eating healthfully not that I'm not I am
too but it's funny you know you can have
relatives that are you know not into
that but then when they start down that
journey and guess who's the first person
that come to ask well they know about it
I'm gonna go ask them right now you can
be that person you can be the person
that stands and you can be the person
that leads people to Christ by your
example there are times we're in this
world
we're blindsided right you go into the
you know into a store you go into a
friend's house you find yourself and you
and it may be an awkward situation
there's something on TV you didn't want
to see that all right or you shouldn't
have seen that and hopefully that's
never situation
you know your kids in but likely they're
gonna have to learn how to deal with
those kind of situations too so it can
be hard to avoid right
I mean it's blaring everywhere you go to
Walmart and they have TVs with stuff on
it just like all the time you know what
at the gas station yeah gas station they
got the little TVs right gas station TV
putting stuff in front of people
all the time and there's stuff
you don't want to subject yourself to
one of the best defenses though is to
run away and I don't mean that in a Sara
Lee a literal physical sense all the
time but there are times where
physically you're gonna have to remove
yourself from a situation yeah I'm not
gonna take part of that I'm gonna turn
and walk the other way it can be you
know if you're at the gas station a
little TV has something on there you
should be I mean turn around do
something else yeah you go to a
restaurant they have a TV on the wall
sit with your back to the TV so run away
in the in the sense that you need to
turn from that right you can you can
flee from that like you're allergic to
it like you're allergic to it
all right so our last question and all
these key questions is will it draw me
toward worldliness or toward godliness
is it drawing me to be more like the
world and living like the world and not
carrying that Jesus because coming again
or is it calling me towards being
heavenly minded in heavenly things and
walking towards the heavenly City of the
New Jerusalem I see a pattern in
entertainment you know we've covered
this a million times in all the
different little shows that we've done
on on movies and cartoons and music
there's this like you know do whatever
you want whatever you see fit for you
and what's right for you is not the same
as that's right for everyone else and it
sort of do is that wilt is kind of the
message to me that's a very worldly
message you know just looking at the
song that was sung in this this halftime
show it at the Super Bowl you know
Jayla ends the whole thing with singing
a song to her little daughter that was
like you know be who you want to be and
be whatever you'd want to do and embrace
all that and it doesn't fun don't follow
someone else's rules or whatever those
are those those lyrics except when we
get home then you have to follow my
rules
and to me it's like you know God's
government in his world is there is
structure to it there is meaning for you
know why you don't cheat on your spouse
why you don't steal from people that you
know isn't it's not yours why you don't
covet everybody else's stuff so I see
worldliness is is kind of that mentality
I got to get mine before you got to get
yours and God's government is like no I
need to lay down my life so that you
know someone else can have a better life
if all of this when you when you look at
all these brenton principles and key
questions and all this if this is gonna
work in your life you have to be in it
for the long haul we need to make
lasting habits and habits are made up of
choices right daily choices what are we
gonna do are we going to follow after
the world or are we gonna follow after
Christ and the beauty of it is we don't
we don't have to be like the world
Christ has given enough ample promises
in his word that can uphold us that can
strengthen us that can encourage us and
we can die to these things right so if
it's if it's if it's evil if it's
lustful if it's whatever it is we have
the strength and power in Jesus to
overcome those things and they don't
have to be part of our lives and and
we're not gonna be asking ourselves what
can I get away with what can i watch
it's what can I get away with what's the
lowest common denominator you know we
should be asking how how high can we how
much can we be like Jesus how much can
we take that high road I've heard it
said like if if it's ever phrased in the
question of like is this salvation --all
then you're always going to default to
do it if you don't think it's salvation
all you know I mean so you know it's
like you have to look at it like that so
again these are these are principles
they are not specifics we are not here
to tell you to make the list what you
can watch what you can't watch the
bottom line is you need to go to the
Bible you need to say what does the
Bible say what is Christ asking of me in
each and every situation and the truth
is we live in a sinful world but each
one of us need to die to sin and we need
to be brought back as a new creation in
Christ and that new creation if it's if
it's filled with the Holy Spirit is not
gonna be aiming for you know the bottom
rung it's gonna be aiming high and
saying how can I be like Jesus what's
the best I can do in each and every
situation and it's gonna want nothing to
do with the things of this world so I
encourage you take time take inventory
evaluate your life and ask yourself
these hard questions and then make those
little choices so that each day you can
form new habits and and it will be your
blessing we have a free download that we
want to give to you as part of this
discussion you can use it for a Bible
study you can use in your own personal
study power packed with lots of
information a lot of verses that we
covered in this show and some that we
didn't so that you can study this out
see of what we're saying is true right
Jesus says you know taste well the Bible
says taste and see that the Lord is good
and so we want you to to do that for
yourself we want you to taste and see I
encourage you to to subscribe to our
Channel
this is a little different topic but it
was kind of one that was requested you
know again you guys give talk about
media principles and what we can watch
what we can't watch that kind of thing
and so we have lots more videos coming
on all kinds of topics little expose is
and all kinds of stuff so I encourage
you to watch subscribe click that belly
so you can be notified when the next
video comes out and stay tuned for those
who are patriots for our post show
discussion we will catch you next time
this has been LED live
[Music]